remember all those righteous types going
after trump for not wearing a mask
but he's a role model they scream he's
killing people
of course away from the cameras they
were doing something else
that's the difference between trump and
politicians with trump
what you see is what you get the others
well
they're politicians like nancy caught at
a hair salon monday
despite laws keeping them closed for the
public
this is the same nancy who said this
the white house by bringing all those
people there
no mask no distancing and the rest he
slapped science right in the face
and what a bad example that was what a
bad
example she should know then there's the
philly mayor caught eating inside a
maryland restaurant while his city bans
indoor dining and our beloved new york
leaders spotted outside
fresh after lecturing citizens on the
rules that they violate
so what's the lesson here why do many
people seek political
power to begin with it isn't to increase
your quality of life
it's to increase theirs by allowing them
immunity
from the laws they enforce being a
politician means
having that special past that gets you
in front of every
disney ride it means the best seat in
the house the ability to bump anyone off
a flight
to be able to run red lights to get to
that gym across town
environment be damned if you talk the
talk there's no need to walk the walk
ask joe biden politics gets you perks
and fame
look at the entire clinton brood who
expected and got millions
after languishing in taxpayer-funded
property and then there are the obamas
netflix-sponsored fat cats so is trump
in this for the money or the perks
well he's got that already so what's he
in it for
did the media ever ask that no they were
too busy trying to
score free tickets to hamilton
all right we just got uh tape of nancy
pelosi
responding to this uh i guess you would
call it hair gate
and she air gate that sounds like a
product we would sell
about 2 am hair gates anyway okay let's
just roll the
roll the tape i'll shut up this salon
owes me an apology
for setting up it was clearly a setup i
take responsibility
for falling for a setup buy a
neighborhood salon
that i've gone to for years
so dana she's taking responsibility for
being screwed over by the salon which is
kind of interesting
um i want you to comment on that but
i'll just clap for her yeah it was
pretty pretty clever
is it sexist dana is it sexist
to criticize nancy over this or is it
sexist
to believe she deserves exemption
because of her sex
and not criticize it very difficult
question for you to answer
i'm just gonna criticize it okay uh
whether sexist or not
um i have to say i did not see this one
coming no
i did not see this excuse coming that is
absolutely
shameless brilliant matt whitlock if you
don't follow him on twitter you've
really got to follow him
he put or her press conference just
there to the sound of the veep
credits at the end because it really is
something that you might see from them
unbelievable um i do think it's also
interesting like when
the way that she goes on and it was like
right after that that she gave that
interview saying that
if the president isn't wearing a mask
he's going to kill people um and look i
think that
it also proves that in a way they're
just like us yeah
they want to be better than us but
they're not that they still got to get
their hair cut and they still got to do
all of these things
and i think that a lot of the data
that's coming in is saying that the
lockdowns
were not productive they did not work
and in the meantime
nancy pelosi is overseeing a legislative
negotiation
in which salons like the one that she
went to would not get any money
yeah her version of the bill um but
she's
forcing them to open just for her and in
addition to that
um there's like this ruling class notion
i guess that's what you were talking
about right like if you're part of the
ruling class
then the rules don't apply to you which
is sort of weird and a little bit of a i
don't know if that's an oxymoron but it
should be
it's the point of trying to get into the
ruling class so you don't have to
abide by the rules that you enforce on
others yeah i thought i made that clear
dana in the monologue
but i'll try better next time you know
emily um
i often wonder if beauty parlor hair is
overrated
like so why do we demand women of a
certain age
to go to a beauty parlor and they're put
under these massive machines i'll show
you some of these pictures because
these things are quite frightening and
intimidating i don't know where they
come from who's that guy who keeps
walking behind me but look at this i
find this quite disturbing
um what where do you stand on this this
incredible scandal that is basically
breaking the world wide open right now
well look i am grateful for each and
every one of those
machines i'll tell you right now greg
these guys have been surfing
the hypocritical wave for decades no one
should be surprised there have always
been two sets of rules right
for those who make the laws and for
those who have to follow them
from chappaquiddick to bill clinton to
the slush fund
from foia to osha to the ethics and
government act of 1978
those rules don't apply to congress
those laws don't apply to congress
it's the reason why the mayor here of
seattle jenny durkin gets a 24-hour
off-duty police security detail while
the residents around chaz
go law enforcement free and why your
mayor de blasio there in new york rolls
in a caravan of suvs to the gym every
day
while the rest of you have to comply
with environment ethics
i mean the entire thing is absolutely
transparent and the worst part is that
we expect it
last month our approval rate of congress
was 21 and there's a record low of
17. we talk about privilege in this
country and people who have privilege
there is no more privileged group in
this country
than those entrenched incumbents on the
hill
absolutely right juan do you agree with
me uh that nancy pelosi should go to
jail and serve at least three to five
years for what she's done
wow you know what you are so kind i
think you i think you're going easy on
her greg yes
i mean to me to me i i thought boy
if she walked through that parlor and
she was holding a pint of ice cream
that would really really have set it off
remember when she had the ice cream
on james gordon behind her the president
the president ran an ad about it right
he said oh look nancy pelosi and the
elites are eating fancy ice cream
uh so i think look she opened herself to
this charge of hypocrisy by the way
emily
i think the rich are the ones who are
privileged in american society by far
um they're the ones who get to the front
of line in disney i can tell you
uh but to my mind to my mind she
she is she did you know i think a
service to
right wing memes and right wing
commentators who want to say hey
nancy pelosi you are a hypocrite now i
will say
you know she didn't put anybody else at
risk
i think that's the best argument i don't
like what she said about the salon
if she's going to be a responsible
person take responsibility
but she didn't put anybody else at risk
and i can't say that
about the republican national convention
uh at the white house i can't say that
about the rally in tulsa where people
got sick and
the protests so the massive protests and
the rioting and the
no because i don't know about they're
wearing masks in other words no
politician was leading that
but but i was thinking you know what i
want to say the biggest hypocrisy of the
day
i think goes to melania trump who was
found to have been using
private email server while at the white
house i think hillary clinton somewhere
eating ice cream and laughing
yeah but she didn't acid wash it i think
that's what it was called she was a
secretary of state
yeah you know so jesse i realize that
you're in a tight spot
on one hand this is great for trump
and bad for the democrats but on the
other hand you're vain and you
understand nancy
i do and i want to talk about that i
want to wade into the whole sexism thing
so
if dana will virtually hold my hand here
i'm about to make some stereotypical
announcements
it is true that women are more beautiful
than men
and that women because they're more
beautiful maybe spend more time
maintaining their beauty and that
women's hair
is longer than men's hair and needs to
be
maintained more and as you mature
perhaps you may need to color
said hair more often now am i doing okay
so far
no okay dana didn't squeeze me yeah she
didn't squeeze me now
as some as someone that goes on tv
almost daily as nancy pelosi does and as
a very
powerful woman she needs to maintain
that look
we all also agree that gavin newsom
shutting down hair salons at this stage
of the pandemic
seems a little excessive and we also
agree that as the number three rated
show
on cable news perks come along with that
and we all love our perks we also know
that each of us maybe has
kind of gone astray when it comes to the
regulation and maybe have
let our mass slip down below our mouth
on occasion
so we understand what nancy did and
she's
just like the rest of us greg the only
difference is
she doesn't walk the walk yeah because
she's a hypocrite
yeah all right well uh
jessie hang on hang on greg yes hey greg
i want to know what perks jesse's
getting i'm not getting any perks what's
going on what's going on
your life is a perk